so let's go ahead and start we have some
compulsive rule followers who were
carefully drinking their coffee outside
let's go ahead and have a roof talk to
us about communication complexity thank
you so I'm gonna give it to our talk on
communication complexity it's kind of
hard to figure out what to talk about
because it's a huge area and teach two
semesters on it and so what I try to do
is maybe a little bit unusual so first
I'm going to sort of give you tell you a
little bit about why I am I like really
like communication complexity and then
I'm gonna discuss some very basic
results but I hope that some of you will
still see something really new and what
I discuss so maybe maybe let me first
start with just the big picture of why
I'm drawn to communication complexity so
this is a picture that it took me some
time being in theoretical computer
science to realize that this is what the
picture was and one once I realized that
this is what the picture is it was
really drawn to communication complexity
communication complexity is this really
simple model computational model but it
has this outsized role in how it
connects different ideas in theory and
out and outside theory so on the one
hand it's a really natural and beautiful
model and that means that a lot of
diverse ideas from mathematics say
something about it
so you know old results in mathematics
from areas like geometry information
theory cognate oryx they all seem to say
something about the same model the model
of communication complexity so that's
one aspect that it has and that means
that if you work in communication
complexity you get to interact with
these very beautiful concepts and areas
so one thing I really like about it and
on the other hand
the results that are proven
communication complexity then get used
by a really large family of different
areas the lower bounds proved in
communication complexity have been used
to prove lower bans on circuits improve
complexity we already saw pavel
mentioned some of these applications on
streaming algorithms and branching
programs data structures and
understanding the extension complexity
of polytopes and in distributed
computing and this list is just it keeps
growing so you know it just keeps
growing and this I hope also will keep
growing growing at a slower pace but so
the upshot is you know I don't think
there is any danger that communication
complexity is a is a fad because of this
this picture you know all of these
different models really care about
communication one way or other so you're
you're guaranteed that if you hear if
you work on this then you will if you
solve these important questions here you
will have an impact so that's why I like
thinking about communication complexity
I think it's really important and
beautiful now as for what I'm gonna do
today I realized that I couldn't really
do justice to this side of the picture
they take a long time to explain so what
I'm gonna try and do is mostly focus my
time on this side of the picture and
that's also it's it's both very
interesting and I think a lot of people
don't know about that side of the
picture as well as they know about the
side in complexity so I think in in in
this audience maybe you'll learn more
from me talking about this side so
that's what I'll do but first so let me
mention that let me plug my book so I'm
here and I've been writing working on a
textbook to capture all of this and it
should be ready sometime early next year
but there's a there's a draft that's
available on my website so if you're
curious go take a look and we welcome
your comment
so what I'm gonna do for the for the
rest of the talk is I want to quickly
sort of tell you about three directions
that are that have very interesting open
questions there
all three are pretty fundamental and but
but also there's been relatively recent
progress on all three questions so I
think there are good questions this is
think about so I'll quickly do that and
then I'll start telling you a little bit
about communication protocols and some
of these applications so the the first
direction I want to talk about is the
famous log rank conjecture so what is
the conjecture suppose you have two
players were trying to compute a
function you know so suppose you have
the set up where you have two parte
communication complexity so there are
two parties Alice and Bob each has an
input and they want to compute some
function f of X Y then a natural way to
think of what they're doing is to think
of them as trying to find an a find an
entry of a new matrix okay so you can
you can encode the function f so that
really you can think of their inputs as
IJ and they're trying to compute the mi
you know the IJ the entry of the matrix
an entry in a boolean matrix and once
you encode the function in this way then
it's natural to talk about the rank of
this matrix and the log rank conjecture
says made by Louis and Sachs says that
says that the communication complexity
of this problem is closely related to
the log of the rank it's up to
polynomial it's polynomial e related to
the log of the rank of this matrix
that's a conjecture it's a really simple
conjecture it's really beautiful and
there's been recent progress on it so
Lobos and sex made this conjecture
sometime the
in the early 90s or late 80s but only a
few years ago lavet building on work
with gavin ski and others proved that so
it's it's easy to see that the
communication complexity of such a
problem is always at least the log of
the rank and in terms of upper bounds
the conjecture is that it's bounded by
poly log of the rank and what the vet
sure is that it can be bonded by square
root of the rank times a lot of fact
it's also easy to show that it can be
bounded by just the rank so he improved
the bond from the sort of easy upper
bound of rank two square root of rank
and it's a really beautiful proof it
involves a very nice result from convex
geometry called John's theorem that I
really like so so so that's what he
proved and the conjecture is that it can
be brought all the way down to poly log
of rank now I just want to mention
because the concept might show up later
today there's another way to look at the
rank of matrix which is you can define
the non-negative rank of a matrix and
the non-negative rank is just the
minimum R such that the matrix M can be
expressed as the sum of our Rank 1
non-negative matrices if you remove the
non negative condition here you exactly
get back the definition of rank so it's
just insisting that your breakdown and
rank one matrices is non-negative and
for for non-negative rank we do know
that the communication is sort of tall
nominally related to the rank so this is
a result of low vos
conjecture is equal to thing right plus
and rank are sort of us almost I think
it's equivalent to saying that they're
related for boolean matrices so yes it's
kind of interesting so when a matrix is
not boolean the non-negative rank can be
arbitrarily far from the rank yeah it's
a simple example that shows us but I
think when the matrix is boolean then
it's really equivalent to saying that
the non-negative rank is close to the it
was there is a rotation like this for
partial functions and is that known for
partial patterns I don't know anyone
that's the rank of a partially deployed
matrix you can minimize over all
matrices but then the question is
whether analyzing boolean matrix
I don't know and actually maybe one more
nice feature of I can see that my
ambitions for timing are already great
going to be off but this is it's it's
okay whatever we talked about it will do
well so a very nice feature of this
proof actually if you don't like
thinking about communication it's
nothing to different communication
almost what what what lavet actually
proved is that if you have a boolean
matrix of rank R then there's a
monochromatic sub matrix of density to
the minus square root R this is the key
step they prove if there's a boolean
matrix of rank R then it has a
monochromatic sub matrix of density to
to the minus square root R and that
squared R is this square root of so just
improve that squared R to 2 to the minus
poly log R and that's really what this
is about
show that low ranked matrices have large
monochromatic summations and yeah it's
more or less equivalent it's just a
statement about the kana toriel
properties of low rank matrices it's
this number so whatever you get here so
what is the dense definition so the the
def the definition means that the size
of the sub matrix the sub matrix covers
a 2 to the minus square root r fraction
of all the entries in the matrix so
maybe I'll write it here so is that if m
has right
this means that M has sub-matrix and L
has covers
- the - squirt our fraction in that was
constantly one oh yeah
monochromatic signatures for square make
it doesn't need to be square the sign
point
okay so and as module is planning out
that that's essentially equivalent to
the log rank conjecture okay so whatever
parameter you find here that parameter
is the same as the parameter here okay
so that's one direction another
direction that I really like worked on
is understanding the relationship
between information of messages in
protocols and the communication required
transmitted so I don't want to spend too
much time getting into it but I'll just
say so given a communication protocol
that's randomized so there's some
imagine that there's a distribution on
inputs X and Y and the parties
themselves can use randomness to
communicate messages about these in fact
these inputs there's a natural way to
define the information that the parties
learn from these messages so not all
messages communicate information you
know if I send Alice completely random
string this is completely this is
useless in terms of the amount of
information communicates about my input
so you can you can use chance Shannon's
notions of information to measure to
quantify exactly how much information is
contained in the messages and the very
nice questions you can ask nice
questions about you know how is the
information related to the communication
so can you simulate any C bit protocol
any protocol that communicates C bits
that has information I with a small
amount of communication so the best
result we we have in this direction is
that you can simulate such a protocol
with communication that's proportional
to square root the damage basically the
geometric mean of the information and
the original communication log factors
and this is crewed by
women Barack chanted myself for a queer
mention myself and very recently sure
stuff showed that in in the indicates
that in the case of the inputs X and y
are independent you can simulate this
with communication that looks like I
poly log I so it's still open to improve
these kinds of bonds in general so so
maybe here what you could hope to do is
prove that such a protocol can be
simulated with communication I times
poly log see is always a lower bound on
C as always at most C ok so it's another
direction so it's a whole world so I if
you didn't follow it it's ok but there
are very nice questions of this type
yeah the previous boat was about the
deadly yes that's true yeah yeah so this
this is about here I was talking about
deterministic protocols and here it's
about randomize protocols and now I'm
gonna talk about a third kind of model
and that's the so this is the last
another direction where I think there's
tons of open questions and also
relatively recent progress which maybe
not everyone is aware so this is the
number and forehead model of
communication so in this model of
communication you have K parties and
each of them has an input that's on
their forehead so each of them can see
everyone else's input but not their own
not the input that's on their forehead
and they're trying to compute some
function that depends on all of their
inputs so this model has a ton of
applications lower bounds on this model
I have ton of applications to things
like circuits and proofs so it's very
important in that sense and we've known
for a while
yes the early 90s eighties you know Baba
and you sign integrity showed lower
bounds of the type and over for the King
in this month's show that there are
functions very natural functions that
require an oath for the K bit suit to
communicate in this model and one really
interesting example is the disjointness
function which it turns out for
applications is particularly important
to keep short showing up over and over
when you talk about this side of the
picture as well and and they're the best
lower bound for randomize protocols was
proved maybe four years ago by sure stop
you showed and this is after a long
sequence of works with many ideas
eventually reach the bound of squared n
over two to the case so so here the
inputs to the parties are sets and they
want to know if sets on the universe one
through n and they want to know if the
intersection of all these sets is empty
or not and this remains the best bond we
have for randomized protocols you can
prove that you need squared n over 2 to
the K bits of communication and
following this work a mirror and myself
improved this bond to N or for the K for
deterministic but there's still an open
question of how can you you know get rid
of the square root n for randomized
protocol so that's one open question
which I think might be in reach and but
maybe the most important question in
this in this debate is just finding any
function for which you can prove a lower
bound of the type and over poly
polynomial in K instead of n over
exponential thank you for this join this
is explanation of this
yes so for for both the generalized
inner product and disjointness and
actually a wide class of functions you
can show that there are protocols that
can get upper bounds that that that look
like an over 40 so in in in all these
actually the the known upper bounds is
like n over 2 to the K so actually
another interesting question be very
interesting to me is to change the four
to two in the door bonds because the
upper bounds have the key yeah exactly
yeah yeah so this this model and I think
Pavel will discuss this in a stock so
the reason that it's very nice is that
in this model if you have K players you
can compute every polynomial of degree K
minus 1 very cheaply that's because
every monomial can be seen by one of the
players so this one on this this model
is able to compute polynomials very
efficiently low degree polynomials and
and that's kind of I think how a lot of
the connection from here to lower bounds
okay so that's just a brief tour of some
open questions and what I want to do now
is to actually what I will do is I want
to start by just giving two I don't want
to spend a lot of time defining exactly
what I mean by the communication
protocol because it takes too much time
and maybe it's not worth it but I do
want to give you maybe one or maybe two
examples of really interesting
communication protocols so that's
another thing that I think people don't
talk about so much so there there are
very nice non-trivial protocols that are
very clever and maybe I'll show you two
of them so the first protocol I want to
talk about is due to hostile Anderson
and it's a protocol for word disjoining
okay so we just talked about this
China's function so let me write down
exactly what it what this app is so here
alice and bob that sets
okay so Alice has a set X that comes
from the universe 1 through n and Bob
has a set Y that comes from 1 to N in
addition they these sets are small ok so
the size of X is K and the size of is
key
and they want to somehow communicate
exchanged messages
and figure out what they want to know is
what is the intersection of x and y are
you know are they disjoint or not is
there an element in the intersection
now what one thing you can you can see
is that I think she can't discuss this
yesterday so you can look at this this
function as a matrix and then it turns
out you can prove it's it's not trivial
but you can prove that the this matrix
is full rank and and that implies that
the the deterministic complexity
communication complexity of its problem
is is is full okay which means for if
you want to solve this problem
deterministically you must compute you
must send basically Alice or Bob must
just reveal their their input there's
nothing non-trivial that they can do
which means you must send like to
describe either X or Y takes log of n
choose K bits so this is the
deterministic complexity of this problem
and this is roughly a log n over K
so this is not the protocol that hassel
introduced in designed what they showed
is the the very nice fact that that if
you're allowed to use randomness then
you can solve this problem with K bits
of communication so you save the log
factor very nice idea so you have two
sets x and y they are potentially small
but they come from a huge universe and
we're going to communicate a number of
bits that's independent of the size of
the universe just K bits of
communication so we gave a K bit
randomized protocol
and I just want to describe the idea of
the protocol is really beautiful and
simple
so I'll just describe how it works and
let's just think about one message in
this protocol so let me tell you what
just one message is so here's idea Alice
and Bob are sitting here and what they
what they will do is they will use
randomness share randomness to sample
uniformly random sets z1 z2 from the
universe just to imagine an infinite
sequence of such things so these are
uniformly random sets
of the same universe
and what Alice will do is she will tell
Bob
so I also compute the smallest index
such that first set X is contained in Zi
and I will just send this index to Bob
and the the thing I want to convince you
is that this this index is both cheap to
communicate but also carries a lot of
useful information and their final
protocol will just be repeating this
step they'll alternate this step okay so
in the next step
Bob will find the smallest index such
that Y is contained in ZJ fresh
randomness and then Bob will send that
index to Alice and it will keep
repeating this that's a very elusive
yeah they're just they're huge writing
subsidies the second step book can take
my intersections there yeah exactly yeah
yeah that was gonna be my hard question
but you already solved it yeah so yeah
so what is the point of this protocol
why why is it making a lot of progress
think about let's think about what
happens when x and y are disjoint so the
the claim I want to make is that when x
and y are disjoint this protocol with
very small communication will we'll
quickly figure that out figure out that
x and y are disjoint and why is that
so you think about x and y they're
they're small sets and say they're
disjoint what happens when alice reals
this set zi that's a uniformly random
set that contains x that's the
distribution of Z I so Zi looks like a
completely random set contains X so
typically it will intersect exact
roughly half of Y and Bob can safely
discard this part of why this part is
just completely there's no chance that
this intersects X so this is what Bob
does Bob just completely discard discard
this part so in the next round we're
actually even here Bob can do this in
and repeat this whatever shape is
suggesting but the way I thinking of it
is that they both do this sort of in
parallel and and then do the discarding
and repeat it doesn't matter you get the
same result so the point is that this is
what happens for Zi and for 4zj
something similar happens right and this
part
Alice can discard so when x and y are
disjoint in each step they're discarding
half of their their sets roughly so in
the next step they're they're trying to
solve exactly the same problem but the
sets of shrunk by a factor of two okay
and moreover what is the cost of this
step well if you think about so for any
particular Z here the probability that X
is in Z is 2 to the minus K because
there are K elements in X and they must
all be contained in Z this happens
exactly with probability 2 to the minus
K so typically you would expect that the
value this index the first index I that
will contain X would be like 2 to the K
so communicating this index should take
K bits of communication so this you
expect would take K bits to communicate
and that's that's pretty much the whole
truth so here you spend like K plus K
bits roughly to communicate in the next
step you will communicate typically K
over 2 plus K over 2 and after that K
over 4 plus cure for this is a
geometrically decreasing sequence so
with order K bits of communication
you will if the sets are disjoined they
will end up with empty sets yeah there
and necess look in the sky yeah so it
turns out you know so it turns out that
any protocol where the randomness is
flipped in the sky can be converted into
one cheaply where the randomness is
flipped in the hand okay but I want to
discuss that will break there there will
be a cost it's like log of the number of
bits in the input but it'll be additive
so it'll be so better than this okay so
that's the protocol I'm not this is the
level of detail at which I was going to
explain this so if anyone has any more
questions this is a few rounds of
communication to do this that's a good
question i I guess this takes log K
rounds I don't know if I don't know if
it's round up tomorrow from somebody is
sure that this was okay cyclamen Irish
have tight round mounds on this okay and
this is on that point more questions are
coming
yes no just kbits because there will be
K rounds log K rounds but each
subsequent Iran takes half as many bits
as the previous round because we were
decreasing the size the size and sets go
Buster yeah okay simply what if you take
a location is faster in this way if
you're willing to do K lucky yeah yeah
but that's the point so the number of
rounds is super constant but actually
the blow up after the first round is not
super classic it's just a constant
number of bits more constant factor more
more questions
okay that's that's one clever protocol
now I want to show you another clever
protocol mostly because it's a very
clever protocol that I think many people
haven't seen the protocol we discuss at
lunch okay some Madhu knows it but so
this is a protocol in the number of the
forhead model and it's maybe one of the
first communication protocol to define
because it was one of the first papers
so here's the problem actually I'll just
do it for three players in the number of
the forhead model so say you have Alice
Bob and Charlie and the setup is they
each have a number on their forehead and
actually this time instead of being a
bit string it's it's really a number
it's a number from 1 through N and what
they want to know is do these numbers
add up to ends
this is a question that they want to
so a trivial protocol for this problem
would be you just you know each person
just is missing one number so you know
Charlie could tell Alice here's what's
on your forehead that would take log n
bits of communication you just described
this number that's or log n is trivial
and what I'm going to show you is the
protocol to chunder first and lipton
that that shows that you can do it in
order square root login
okay yeah this is gonna be doesn't
determine okay and the connection here
is actually really beautiful because the
way the protocol will come is I will
reduce I will show you that you can use
results from combinatorics to prove this
result and then you can actually show
that the communication complexity this
problem is tightly connected both upper
and lower bounds to problems and comma
Turks randomized is responsible yes
that's a good point yeah
right so if you had a randomized
protocol you could do this with constant
bits of communication because that would
be the same as you know Alice sees two
numbers so you just wants to know he has
a you know there's a the value for
there's an X value that makes us some
equal to n it's unique and Alice just
wants to know whether the X that's on
her forehead is equal to this x value so
just wants to check equality and you can
use hashing to check that quickie the
cost number of bits of range so in for a
randomized protocol it's only a constant
on repetition
so you're saying like Alice could
communicate with just one person Bob to
check our quality yes check whether X
equals n minus y minus E
okay so what is the protocol so the
protocols
so let's first let me tell you a very
nice result many of you have probably
heard of it so it's due to bear and I
realize I don't have to spell this name
so what is there the result
there's a coloring of write and numbers
so you can always color color the the
set of numbers 1 through m with two to
the square root log M colors such that
there will be no monochromatic three
term arithmetic progression in this
color
no monochromatic arithmetic progression
which means no monochromatic points of
the type A plus the
[Music]
so every such triple of distinct numbers
one of them will get a different colors
from the others
so that's that's the result that I want
to use and you know you see a square
root log in here so that's going to be
the complexity of this protocol so that
now the protocol is given this coloring
is really simple let me tell you what it
is so let's let's look at let's look at
two numbers so here's the setup there's
XYZ on Alice Bob and Charlie's forehead
consider the number X prime which is n
minus y minus Z okay and this is a
number that Alice can read so Alice
knows this and then there's a number of
y prime which is n minus X minus Z and
this is something that Bob knows
here's an observation the difference
between X and X Prime that's equal to X
plus y plus Z minus
n which is also equal to the difference
between y and y Prime
so so hiding in here is a protocol that
uses that coloring so let me let me tell
you what the protocol is so here's the
protocol they just Alice computes X
prime plus 2y Bob computes Y prime plus
OSR X X plus 2 y prime like this X plus
2y X prime plus 2 y and X plus 2 y prime
here are three numbers and Charlie knows
this one Alice knows this one and Bob
knows this one so each number is known
by one of the players ok and what
they're going to do is just check that
they have the same color in this
coloring let's check check if they have
the same color
that's the whole protocol and the point
is that if X plus y plus Z is equal to n
then X prime will be equal to X this
difference will be 0 and y prime will be
equal to Y so all three will be the same
number so they will certainly have the
same color that part is easy the
slightly tricky part is to show that if
this difference is nonzero then they
cannot all have the same color and
that's that's because these are actually
in arithmetic progression right the
difference in these two that's this
number and the difference between these
two is two times the server sorry the
difference between this and the first
one it's two times lisam so they're
really three numbers in arithmetic
progression this is a a plus D and a
mustard
where B is this X minus X all right -
yeah they know the coloring ahead of
time so you know we know there's one
coloring before they see their inputs
everybody agrees on this coloring that's
part of the code of the protocol right
so you imagine that the protocol is
described the description has this yeah
actually it's even yeah that's true
the other thing is that the the coloring
is also very explicit I can tell you but
I want but I wanted to I could tell you
exactly what they sent wait you're the
person that didn't do it is by random
shifts so yeah if it turns out you can
actually not do that yeah that choose to
yeah so it turns out the coloring looks
something like you view these numbers
you write them in a particular base
basis as even if you look at the digits
in a theory representation and then you
send some statistics about the vectors
that you get like the length of these
vectors and some others I think partly
in general protocols are allowed to be
non-uniform yes if we depend partly on n
and others yes each collects rapidly
first coloring around true yeah that too
okay so
okay so here too these are two
interesting part any more questions
hi this tight yes actually I wanted to
talk about that right sorry I forgot
about that part yeah so what
Chandler person Lipton short actually is
that so here is some problem from
comment uruk's but what they what they
showed is that there's another problem
from combinatoric is called the
coroner's problem okay this is the
question if you have a n by n grid and
you want to color the points to avoid a
monochromatic corner okay the corner is
something like this where this distance
is D and this is this is an old problem
combinatoric the question is how many
colors do you need to color the N by n
grid so that there are no monochromatic
there are no monochromatic corners and
it turns out the the answer there is
directly related so actually the same as
the communication complexity of this
problem up to Italy there are some logs
involved but the answer to this question
is the same as the answer to this
question so that's why maybe it's not so
so the way you can find this coloring is
actually they're all results relating
this question to this question this one
is also not exactly and this was not
known so the best lower bound right so
to your question in terms of
communication the best lower bound you
can get from results on that problem is
like Omega log log N
there's an exponential gap between these
two but if you could close this gap you
would be really solving very old
problems problems over in complexity
what do we know for everything I said
can be generalized some more than three
parties in both the upper bounds and
disconnection the parameters get more
hairy so for more than three parties
it's like trying to find the coloring
that avoids four term
arithmetic progressions I think is
enough it's more like and here it
becomes like a multi-dimensional like
you have a three-dimensional grid and
then you're looking for this structure I
believe that's that's true although I
haven't carefully checked
more questions or
okay so
I expected not to meet my expectations
in terms of time but I think it's good
so what I'm gonna do
this is these expected yeah try not to
meet that okay so the the these are two
protocols which I think they're clever
and now what I want to show you is some
sort of the right the some connections
to the right side of the board that from
what I've you know for it for this line
yeah yes so right okay so for yeah for
for disjoin us we do know that yeah then
this is basically tight you need you
need K bits if you have sets of size K
even with the randomized protocol
because I skates yeah even if the
universal size K and you have sets of
size K you need it is
okay so the the first the first
connection I want to show from
communication to something that doesn't
look like as anything to it
communication is I want to prove lower
bands on boolean formulas so this is an
old result of magic pork and he didn't
explain it there was no communication
complexity when you prove this result so
it doesn't explain in terms of
communication but actually it's really
is the result of our communication so I
want to show you how that in viewed like
that so what did Mitch pork proved so he
was interested in in in the model where
you have a formula and the gates can
compute arbitrary functions of the
inputs so the circuit where circuits
we're looking at our trees looks like
this and every gate here computes some
arbitrary function
right a little bit longer because I'll
use it okay so that's the formula every
gate computes some arbitrary function of
inputs and and what he showed is give an
example of a boolean function that
requires high complexity in this model
the complexity here is just a number of
wires or nodes it's the same okay so the
function we're going to be interested in
is the element distinctness function or
cygnus function so what is that function
the function Maps numbers it's given n
numbers from the set 1 through 2 n ok
it's a boolean function and the way it's
defined you look at the N numbers x1
through xn and you output 1 if they're
distinct you actually have n distinct
numbers there and 0 otherwise
that's emotion and the theorem is that
this requires Omega N squared size
now I did something a little bit tricky
here so maybe it's confusing so the
input length is n log n if that's where
the log is going it's usually in this
robot the input length is n log N and
now the lower bound will be like N
squared so that's the result I want
proven I want to show you how you can do
it with communication yeah yes yeah
yeah other questions about the model
login well I'm gonna prove like sorry
better you're proving N squared over log
squared if you use N squared as your why
they're coming luck Squared's if he is N
squared is your domain
oh I see I see okay there might be yes
if used N squared into the two and
you'll get a better bound in terms of
its it's okay
yeah so I guess I'm not doing the right
setting of parameters but I will stick
with it okay so it's interesting because
there there's an obviously a
communication I mean the the first thing
is to think about the relationship
between communication and circuits is
that the gates are communicating with
each other okay but that's not you know
that's not going to be the reduction
that are actual is gonna be pretty
clever so here's the problem will reduce
- so consider the following problem
Alice is given a set X as a subset of -
n of size exactly n actually besides n
minus 1 and Bob has an element I and
they want to know is I in X but the the
protocol is restricted the the way the
protocol works it's a really simple
protocol Alice is just going to send a
message and then Bob needs to be able to
answer this question is I guess
so Alice has a set that has roughly half
of the elements in the universe Bob has
an element Alice needs to send a message
and then Bob needs to figure out is is
his his his element in the set X and
it's pretty easy to see that you need
Omega that basically you have to Alice
must describe the set right if there's
any uncertainty about what the set is
then Bob cannot figure figure out you
know if Bob can answer this question for
every I that means Bob must know this
set so the kind of a trivial lower bound
that you need you need actually log of
and choose to n choose n minus 1 which
is 2 to the 2 n divided by square N and
we take logs
the 1/2 is here okay so this is required
and now I want to show you that if you
have any if you have any such formula
actually you if you have a formula that
has size significantly less than N
squared you violate this ok so I want to
go from the size bound in this formula
to to a communication protocol and let's
do it so how does it work
so suppose you have a formula that has
suppose you have such a formula and it
has less than epsilon times and squared
leaves you know in a formula the number
of leaves is essentially the same as the
overall size there within constant
factors of each other just the common
Toric's of trees so if the size is small
and sore the number of lis well that's
the tribulation the number of leaves is
at most epsilon times N squared and and
this means that here you have n
variables right one of them must be read
less than epsilon n times just by Irish
applies so it implies that there Absalon
n leaves reading a bit from some input
there's some input some J such that at
most epsilon and leaves read from X J so
let's let's look at all of these leaves
and say they're here so I'm gonna draw
squares around them so this is one of
them this is way more than epsilon n but
it helps to to understand what I'm doing
next so so these are now the set of
leaves that read from XJ so just to
understand what's gonna happen in with
Allison Bob Alice is going to get all
the elements that are not the j1 and Bob
is going to get just the J element and
that's what's going to happen in Russian
so now so now now I'm going to do
something just in pictures which I hope
should we continue convincing so
consider this tree
okay so that's a tree that's defined by
these leaves basically you take all the
paths from a leaf to the root and I sort
of only considered those nodes where two
of these paths converge this gives me a
tree and this tree has a small number of
edges right it's basically sort of looks
like a formula every vertex has two
children and the number of leaves is
only epsilon n so the number of edges in
this tree is small this is this is going
to be important for how we assign the
protocol so now let me tell you how the
protocol works so looking at this
picture you know Alice has the subset X
and she will just set X 1 through you
know up to X J minus 1 XJ plus 1 and
these are the elements that she will set
from X this set these out Bob that's why
Bob his I she'll just said to be X J and
now they want to do something with this
formula they want to communicate I mean
Alice need to send Bob a message but
Alice is going to send only order
epsilon n bits in the message and Bob
will be able to compute whether or not
XJ is one of these elements the point is
that you know if XJ is one of these
elements then these n elements are not
distinct okay and if actually is not one
of these elements than these elements
are distinct so if you can compute the
output of this formula on these inputs
we're done but now Alice's need to send
a small a short message so that Bob can
compute the output and Bob's not allowed
to speak so I wonder if someone who
hasn't seen this before has an idea of
how
so that the hint is that you sort of
want to compute only a constant number
of bits per edge in this picture so
Alice knows all of the non square nodes
here she doesn't know the inputs n
square but she wants to send Bob enough
information to compute the output here
she's gonna send only a constant number
of bits per edge over gate or per gate
yeah yeah maybe every other yeah she she
knows what the sort of the function in
terms of XJ is for each gate
so that's you know two bits max so she
can just send that for each gate exactly
yeah very good so the point is although
there for example in this path you know
if Bob knows this value Alice knows all
the values that sort of interact with
this path so the value that's feeding
here is some from Alice's perspective is
some function of this single bit there's
only one bit that Alice doesn't know so
Alice just needs to describe this bit to
Bob this is this function to both so
once Bob knows how to take this bit and
convert it into the input into here in
this bit can write into the input here
you can do that for the whole tree then
then balking computable
so Alice just describes for each of
these edges what is the function that
Bob should apply to the bit that's
coming from doing and that's a constant
number of bits per edge here so that
gives you over all epsilon bits of
communication violates that
any questions about that reduction
okay so I'll stop here and then when we
return we will talk about more
reductions to bring lower bond in
circuits and other ones
[Applause]